Before we say goodbye,
let's play a quick round
of Drewth or Dare
because you can ask me anything
or dare me to do anything.
And we have Terry Perry here.
Hi Terry.
Hey, Drew.
Do you know how happy your name is?
Very, no relation to Tyler but you know?
Well, it's giving me joy.
Drewth or Dare?
Drewth.
Okay.
So we had two lovely sisters here earlier
and you gifted them ornaments.
What's one of your favorite ornaments
during the holiday season?
One of my favorites is a mushroom.
I was in Northern California
and I was like in a little town,
like on Main Street,
and I bought this little mushroom,
and it was one of the first ornaments I collected,
and I was pregnant.
And I just thought here is where it begins.
So let's begin.
(audience cheering)
And it's my first ornament that I bought.
And it's still my favorite.
So thank you for asking me, Terry Perry.
No problem, Drew Barrymore.
And the happiest of holidays to you.
And thank you for choosing to spend your time with us.
We make this show for you,
so take it with you.
(upbeat music)